stéphanie vallée bonjour bonjour vous
êtes donc l'une des porte-parole de l'r
des centres de femmes du québec
oui c'est ça alors aujourd'hui nous
allons parler de relance post pandémie
on sait que ça a été très très loin
depuis l'année dernière
tout le monde est un mois de hausse et
beaucoup d'inquiétude on ne sait pas
quand est ce qu'on va sortir de cette
histoire mais avec les vaccins quand
même il ya un peu d'espoir qui pointe à
l'horizon
alors dites-moi de votre côté quelles
sont les activités que vous envisagez
dans les prochains jours en fait en ce
moment on est dans une semaine d'action
des centres de femmes du québec
c'est l'ère des centres de femmes du
québec qui organise et ça pour ses
membres
faut dire que depuis le début de la
pandémie il ya eu puisqu'on pouvait pas
se rencontrer en personne
on a décidé de faire des webinaires à
raison de un ou deux noms 1 1 par
semaine et maintenant on est rentré à
deux par mois qu'on a fait aussi depuis
à peu près le mois de mars pour informer
nos membres dans le fond des mesures
center entre haute et séduit le gaz est
un peu ce qu'ils disent elles dans les
pointes vers les points de presse leur
donner des outils aussi pour rassurer
les participants les femmes qui
fréquentent les centres de femmes sont
souvent des femmes
bien sûr parfois et souvent des femmes
vulnérables qui ont besoin de leurs
centres de femmes pour briser leur
isolement puis complété leur démarche
alors c'est ça une fois par mois ou deux
fois par mois on mettait un point dans
les webinaires pour pour faire ce qui
appartient à peu près du mois de
septembre
il ya eu des consultations des membres
pour voir qu'est ce qui arriverait après
la pandémie
comment pourrais faire pour pour
améliorer le sort entre des fans de
nairas ben et des travailleuses du
communautaire et des travailleuses au
système de santé qui ont été pour la
plupart les premières au front on le
sait bien comment voudrais tu faire pour
que ça se passe comme ça si région et y
aurait une autre crise est valide les
travailleuses du système de santé du
réseau de la santé on était tout le
temps en première ligne ça n'a pas du
tout été simple pour elle il se trouve
aussi que durant cette pandémie
les femmes ont été davantage due aux
victimes de violences conjugales
donc c'est un mal qui a atteint son
paroxysme durant cette crise sanitaire
j'imagine que au niveau du regroupement
des centres de femmes vous avez
également abordé cette problématique
oui ça se fait c'est beaucoup par
téléphone et comme les femmes qui
fréquentent les centres de femmes vont
souvent se retrouver dans des milieux de
vie
pis les travailleuses ce sont deux
femmes son habileté de dépister ou faire
faire reconnaître que les femmes vivent
la violence quand ça se retrouve dans
l'île dans les milieux de vie dans les
salons tout seul et les femmes se
mettent à parler de ce lot il y avait pu
cet endroit là sécuritaire donc on a eu
à composer avec souvent les femmes qui
nous appelaient et qui avait le conjoint
violent
derrière eux ça que ça donnait vraiment
des façons m'as les antes à ce moment là
on a beaucoup travaillé l'estiment
personnel des femmes essayer de voir
qu'est ce qu'elle pouvait faire lé pour
gagner la confiance en elle
la pibale le rôle de la danse était
aussi de soutenir travailleuses dans ce
travail là parce que c'est c'est
beaucoup décourageant ne pas pouvoir qui
on sent impuissante qu'on peut pas aider
les femmes de façon concrète
puis aussi on a eu affaire rappelle
parfois nos partenaires là des maisons
d'hébergement ti tout seul pour qui ce
qu'on se rend compte aussi c'est que les
femmes étaient peut-être plus comment
peut-on acheter la clé acheter la paix
plus plus haut niveau quotidien est ce
qu'on se rend compte qu'il y avait moins
de vagues dans les maisonnées pour
provoquer de deux épisodes de violence
oui c'est ça c'est que les femmes 15,1
des continents va arriver quand je
compose un ouf de soulagement
oui tu es va être libéré parce qu'ils
vont réduire leur milieu sécuritaire
faut dire aussi que les centres de
femmes étant des services
[Musique]
on dit un sens ciel et non prioritaires
ont pu s'organiser certains centres de
femmes ont pu s'organiser pour continuer
à recevoir des femmes avec des mesures
très strictes intra 6 à 2 mètres chacune
il y en a même qui ont organisé leur
milieu de vie pour pouvoir respecter ses
distances le laver les mains souvent
rentrés par une porte sur sa part
l'autre un peu comme dans l'est dans les
supermarchés ou du magasin ça a
fonctionné ce que les femmes ont
continué à avoir un petit 1 ghana dans
certaines places où c'était possible je
fais voilà et depuis lundi donc vous
avez lancé une semaine d'actions il ya
toutes sortes de choses au programme
vous comptez également rencontré des
élus opposés les problèmes auxquels les
femmes sont confrontées
alors on sait que durant la crise celles
qui ont le plus perdu 1
ce dans la population qui ont le plus
été victime de pertes d'emplois c'est
surtout les femmes et donc c'est des
questions que vous entendez porté à
l'attention des élus mais on a vu que
c'était 68 % des emplois perdus qui
étaient des femmes et ce sont des
milieux où il y avait aussi une sur
représentation des femmes immigrantes et
racisées qui travaillait donc la
restauration les caissières tout ce qui
était permis
ce qui est encore fermée dans beaucoup
de régions
c'était beaucoup des femmes que la
société racisées vulnérables
qu'est ce qui était la question je vous
imagine que c'est des doléances que vous
allez porter à l'attention
oui oui disent en fait on a une
déclaration qui est a été lancé cette
semaine le cheveu la trouver puis s'être
c'est cette déclaration là justement
elle était faite à partir des des
rencontres qu'on a eu depuis
mi-septembre par webinar où les membres
les centres de femmes on était une
centaine 120 109 femmes issus des
centres de femmes qui se rencontraient
sur ce webinaire le donc on a dit c'est
la déclaration en quatre grands volets
le premier volet c'était de donner la
priorité à la santé et au bien-être des
femmes sont on veut faso en investissant
en forçant un en revendiquant
l'investissement de funès dans le filet
social par le financement des services
publics et parapublics
on veut aussi rendre les services
institutionnels de santé services
sociaux et de justice sécuritaire et
accessible pour les femmes le jour
c'est vraiment une longue déclaration
je ne sais pas si vous vouliez qu'on l'a
collard ya disons pas forcément si on
pouvait la résumer oui c'est le danger
la deuxième priorité c'était aux
travailleuses et aux communautés ça
c'était vraiment un investissement des
milieux de soins d'éducation et du
communautaire entre autres aussi
reconnaître la malle à travers la valeur
du travail des femmes
ben encore le surtout des femmes de la
société rassise en arrêtant de les
appeler des anges
ce ne sont pas des anges sont des
travailleuses qui doivent avoir ce qu'on
leur doit
dans une d2 ses revendications lotion
on aimerait en existe en fait dos et le
salaire minimum à 15 $ de l'heure c'est
une vieille revendication le salaire
minimum à 15 heures de l'arrêt on
voudrait aussi verte ici ce qu'un soir
de l'art l'eau peut encore être
d'actualité étant donné que ça fait
longtemps qu on le revendique
c'est comme un petit bout oui c'est ça
qu'il faudrait peut-être le l'index il
mais s'assurer nos revenus dans le fond
qui couvre tous les besoins essentiels
ça serait la base ensuite on a été de
renforcer la résilience pour prévenir de
futures crises et leurs conséquences
ben à 30 et bancaires dont joue en
groupe
il faut que les pouvoirs publics mance a
réservé un budget un budget conséquent
pour venir en aide aux femmes lors de la
relance et conduit j'imagine que c'est
comme une espèce de gâteaux et chacun
devrait avoir sa portion est compris
toutes ces femmes qui ont été laissés
sur le carreau impose de la commune
distincts oui mais c'est aussi une
question de valeurs de notre société
lorsqu'on voit avec le projet de loi 66
c'est que le gouvernement veut investir
lancer dans des infrastructures investir
encore dans des choses que qui va
favoriser excusez-moi l'expression mais
l'homme blanc de classe moyenne ou
réchauffe il s'en sort déjà très bien
aujourd'hui en ce moment le mouvement
revendique ce qui est remettent à
l'ordre du jour
le filet social parce qu'on sait qu'une
société richesse et une société où il y
eu de l'impôt à payer et c'était pour le
sahara essayer d'atteindre une justice
sociale s'est brillamment en gros ce qu
ont revendiqué un particulier d'aider ce
qui était vraiment issu des
conversations ces deux revendiqué aussi
le
[Musique]
une société plus inclusive plus
tolérants avec une société où chacun
trouve son compte de la vie ok j'ai pu
est-ce que vous m'entendez on joue
encore oui donc ces sommes des
discussions avaient avaient mené à ça
donc exigé la résidence permanente aux
femmes migrantes sans statut inscrit
qu'à leurs familles
évidemment qu'ils ou si un autre truc
est assez important dans nos discussions
s'étaient d'appliquer les mesures qui
découlent des trois enquêtes récentes
sur les relations entre les peuples
autochtones et les services publics
parce que pour vrai c'est arrivé à lille
à quoi je réponds oui vraiment vraiment
bouleversée banks et a bouleversé le
québec mais aussi saint john moncton qui
est décédé dans un hôpital de joliette
agents des circonstances vraiment
difficile qui a été complètement
maltraité par le personnel soignant
picon on veut c'est qu'on sait toutes et
tous que c'est du racisme insisté mais
que qui a mené à ce une enquête un an
auparavant les personnes qui
travaillaient dans cet hôpital avait été
consulté et rien n'a été fait c'est
qu'on voudrait aussi danser dans ses
revendications là qu'on a cliqué mesures
qui découlent de ces trois en quatre
lots qui ont été peut-être qu'on arrête
de table étaient les enquêtes
conféraient qui compte l'interaction
particulièrement à ma part aux femmes
disparues lundi qu' au niveau de la
réconciliation entre les peuples
il y avait aussi un autre truc était
quand même assez important pour beaucoup
de monde state national nationaliser
l'internet à haute vitesse à montréal
s'en rend pas trop compte dans les
grands centres saveur
mais en région ces prix là c'est
davantage compliqué c'est vraiment que
ce matin l'accès à cet outil-là aux
familles les plus défavorisées
mais oui et je souci avoir accès parce
qu'il ya des encore des trous de
services à travers le québec il ya des
places parce que c'est toujours très
compliqué hudak s'est logiquement les
données cellulaires sont compliquées est
accès à accéder aussi essayer de rendre
son accident de démocratiser l'accès à
ces outils
oui si on continue à avoir un des
pandémies comme ce pet
force est de faire du télétravail puis
de conques à distance
ben on met de côté toute une population
enfin c'est un 7ème c'est un beau paquet
de doléances et j'espère que vous serez
entendu c'était donc stéphanie vallée
qui est l'une des porte parole de l'aig
des centres de femmes du québec
je vous remercie infiniment d'avoir pris
le temps de nous parler merci ils sont
fait plaisir c'est l'invitation au
revoir